uh let's do uh let's do blake and mr keating
shall we don't go buy a book about terms of
the industry either i'll teach those to you
week by week we'll go through all those terms
you need some help there buddy i have bonnie
gillespie's book it's pretty good so far
bonnie's one of the only books about the
industry that i would highly recommend
self-management fractals yeah it's really fabulous
and she's a very gracious giving human being
she gives away a lot of her time and her energy
then you showed meisner's book the other day i
had read that one i forgot what it was called
she's reading to find out what not to do yeah
i disagree well he talks a lot about repetition
well that's what he based his whole
thing on and that's why my mentor
and coach charles conrad broke away from sanford
and came out here and opened his own studio but
that's another story all good things of all
oh yeah okay you guys ready camera's ready
who starts uh i do okay we're rolling
action dad what's wrong with
grandma she's real sick honey
is she going to die everybody dies
someday i mean is she going to die soon
son come here for a minute let's talk i don't
want to upset you but yes she is going to die soon
but i don't want grandma to die can't the doctors
help her they've done everything they could
for now the best we can hope for is for her to be
comfortable she didn't even know me earlier today
when you get old the body gets worn out and
things stop working the brain is just one of them
but i don't want grandma to die i don't
want her to die either she's my mother
and nobody can ever replace her
mom died and little mickey died
how come everybody i love is dying dad how
come all the good people in the world are dying
i don't know i guess god needs him in heaven to
help him so what why is god taking away all the
people i love what did i ever do to make him
mad you didn't make him mad you're a good kid
and besides he hasn't taken everyone i'm still
here and i'm not leaving you promise i promise
mom promised she would never leave either
and she did she lied and you're lying too
you're gonna leave me just like everybody
else did not for a long long time i promise
i'm going to stay here and watch your kids grow up
i'm not going to have any
kids that way they can't die
and cut lovely good for you that one actually
hurts of course it hurts it's a painful piece
of course it hurts it's supposed to if it didn't
hurt you wouldn't be human see that's what's
so wonderful about this process that charles
taught me and that i teach you that's charles
eric conrad for those of you that don't know
he was not only my acting coach for 12 years
but he was my friend and mentor for 40.
and that's why this process is so wonderful
because it allows you to experience the pain
that you would be feeling if you're actually
going through the situation you don't have
to fabricate anything i'm sorry what it was
just this kid this character lost his mother and
his i don't know who mickey is it's his brother
mickey's his brother so he lost his mother and
his brother and now he's losing his grandma
so you can allow yourself to feel a little bit
more pain if you want to on this second time okay
don't hold back i want to compliment you not one
up read tonight not one not one good for you kiddo
you know we've been working on that fine-tuning it
they're all little things we work on you all know
i do not believe in constructive criticism i think
it's an oxymoron i don't think you could build
something up and tear it down at the same time but
what we can do is because we tape everything and
we look at everything and we see everything and we
send you free copies of everything we shoot here
we can evaluate we can see what's working what's
not working what you're hiding from us see in
theater and i love theater don't anybody say i
don't love theater i've done theater my whole life
i love theater you can get away you can cheat a
little bit in theater you can't cheat on film film
crawls in your eyes and in your guts counts the
nose hairs in your nose and magnifies everything
you do and feel so you can't cheat you know and
that's what's so wonderful about charles process
it allows you once you get your head in the right
space once you go from your left brain which is
the logical brain to your right brain which is a
creative brain once you go there it allows you to
experience things on a real natural personal level
but you have to have the willingness to go there
seeing a lot of people when they're new here
don't have that willingness they don't want
us to see them warts and all they want to smile
through everything or be tougher than everyone but
that's not the way life is you know pain agony and
torture is what life is i'm not a fatalist but i
am a realist you know so allow yourself
to feel that pain when we do this again
see where john is do you see where john's coming
from as as the son of the woman who's your grandma
who's dying he tells you you say i don't want
grandma to die and he what does he tell you
he said he doesn't want to die either why that's
his mom and nobody can ever replace her yeah
yeah pretty serious stuff isn't it yeah
so just feel it a little bit more okay
let yourself go there just don't give a hoot you
know what i normally say but we're being taped
tonight so i have to be polite you know i'm trying
not to swear too much uh they could bleep it out
that's not the way i use the f
word they couldn't give you there
be beep no so okay so we good
in the booth yep okay okay
dad what's wrong with grandma
she's real sick connie
is she going to die everybody dies
someday i mean is she going to die soon
son come here a minute let's talk now
i don't want to upset you but
yes she is going to die soon
but i don't want grandma to die can't the doctors
help her they've done everything they could
now the best we can hope for
is for her to be comfortable
she didn't even know who i was earlier today
when you get old
your body
breaks down things stop working
the brain is just one of them
i don't i don't want grandma to die i don't
want her to die either she's my mother
and nobody can ever replace her i can't believe
this mom died and then little mickey died
how come everybody i love is dying how come
all the good people in the world are dying dead
i don't know i guess god needs him in heaven to
help him but why is god taking everybody away
from me what did i ever do to make him mad you
haven't done anything to make god mad you're a
good kid and besides he hasn't taken everyone
i'm still here and i'm not leaving you promise
i promise mom promised you would never
leave me either and she did she lied
and you're lying too you're gonna leave me just
like mom didn't i just like little mickey did
not for a long long time i promise i'm going
to stay right here and watch your kids grow up
i'm not going to have any
kids that way they can't die
and cut oh nice really lovely yeah good
work good work blake really good thank you
yeah nice mr keating thank you really
super super let's do uh andrea and bet you